space travel is the most exciting and
challenging adventure humanity has ever
undertaken
but in an irony of history we may stop
ourselves from going into space
the more we do it with every rocket
launched
and with every satellite deployed we're
creating a trap for ourselves that gets
deadlier and more dangerous
every year if it's ever activated it
could end the space age
and trap us on our planet for decades or
even
centuries
[Music]
getting something into space is
incredibly hard
to do so you need to move very very fast
at first straight up to leave the
atmosphere
then sideways to begin a sort of
circling around the earth
still very very fast if you do that
successfully
you can enter a low earth orbit and once
in orbit
it's very hard to get out of always
unless you have
energy to spare you're sort of locked in
here falling around the earth forever
that's great for things we want to stay
up like space stations and satellites
and so we moved the majority of
humanity's space infrastructure to this
place
just a few hundred kilometers above the
surface just high enough
so that the atmosphere is so thin that
orbiting things can stay up for
centuries
before air resistance can slow them
enough to bring them back to earth
but this is also the source of our
deadly trap
rockets are really metal cylinders that
keep big piles of fuel in place
whenever a portion of the fuel has been
spent the empty tanks are dropped to
make the rocket lighter
some parts crash down to earth or burn
up in the atmosphere
but most of the useless rocket parts
stay up and begin to orbit the planet
after decades of space travel low earth
orbit is a junkyard of spent boosters
broken satellites and millions of pieces
of shrapnel from missile tests and
explosions
right now we know of around 2600 defunct
satellites
ten thousand objects bigger than a
monitor twenty thousand
as large as an apple five hundred
thousand pieces the size of a marble
and at least one hundred million parts
so small they can't be tracked
this debris is moving at speeds of up to
30 000 kilometers per hour
circling earth on criss-crossing orbits
multiple times a day
orbital speeds are so fast that being
hit by debris the size of a pea
is like being shot by a plasma gun on
impact the debris vaporizes releasing
enough energy to punch holes
straight through solid metal so we've
covered the space around our planet with
millions of deadly pieces of destruction
and we also put a trillion dollar global
infrastructure network
right in the danger zone it performs
critical duties essential to the modern
world
global communication gps and navigation
collecting weather data looking out for
asteroids
and all manner of scientific discoveries
things we would miss very much if they
suddenly went away
if just one pea-sized bullet hits one of
our 1100 working satellites it will be
destroyed
instantly three or four satellites are
already being destroyed this way
every year as the number of satellites
and the amount of junk in orbit is
expected to grow tenfold in the next
decade
we're approaching a tipping point but
the worst thing in space
is not tiny pieces of junk the worst
thing would be an
unstoppable chain reaction that turns a
lot of non-junk things
into junk for example if two satellites
hit each other in just the right way
if satellites collide they don't stop
and fall out of the sky
it's more of a splash than a crash
orbital speeds are so fast solid pieces
spray right through each other
transforming the two satellites into
clouds of thousands of little things
still fast enough to destroy more
satellites
this could trigger the slowest and most
destructive sort of domino effect
a collision cascade like a shotgun spray
each collision creates more bullets what
was once a single tiny target
very unlikely to hit anything becomes a
wall of destruction
hungry to make more as more and more
satellites are destroyed
the destruction accelerates
exponentially eventually destroying
everything parked in orbit but space is
very empty
so the first few collisions may take a
long time
by the time we realize what's happening
it's too late
one year one satellite is destroyed and
that's no big deal
the next year five the year after
50 until there's nothing left
the situation in orbit is rapidly
worsening and we may already be past the
point of no
return within 10 years space around
earth may no longer be viable for
long-term satellites or rockets
the worst case scenario is horrifying
a debris field made of hundreds of
millions of pieces
many too small to track moving at thirty
thousand kilometers per hour
it would effectively create a deadly
barrier around earth
possibly too dangerous to cross dreams
of
moon bases mars colonies or space travel
at all
may be set back centuries and the loss
of our space infrastructure
would send some of the technology we
rely on daily back to the 1970s
but it might not be too late to clean up
our mess while the space industry has
become better at avoiding space junk
it's still growing fast and
occasional weapon tests don't help so
there have been a couple of wild but
also serious suggestions
about how to quickly remove as much
deadly space junk as possible
without creating more in the process
lots of ideas are being thrown around
and some of the most seriously
considered involve
capture and return missions which are
being tested now
one method involves meeting a piece of
junk in orbit with a small satellite
loaded with a net
once caught a small rocket can be used
to bring it down towards earth
targets too large for a net might be
instead caught with a harpoon on a
tether
instead of firing a rocket the cleaner
would deploy a large sail to produce
atmospheric drag and accelerate orbital
decay
and there are lots of other wild sci-fi
sounding proposals too
some might use giant electromagnets
these
magnetic tugs work by pushing on the
magnetic components inside satellites
that they use to stabilize and orientate
themselves in earth's magnetic field
these may be safer and more reliable
than nets and harpoons because
they never have to make contact with the
junk they're handling so there's no risk
of
accidentally breaking up their target
into more junk
as for the tiniest bits of junk lasers
might be the key to vaporizing them
entirely
satellites with lasers wouldn't need to
visit their targets
they can shoot them from far away large
objects can't exactly be shot down
but lasers can be used to ablate them or
burn tiny amounts of material off the
side
to push the junk to a safer orbit
whatever technology we use
in the end we better start doing
something soon
before 100 million bullets become a
trillion
and the trap is set if we don't act our
adventure in space
might end before it's even begun
if our days of dreaming about space
exploration might be numbered anyway
we better put them to good use one of
the things we most like to spend our
time on is learning more about our
universe
and to do that you can just keep
watching kurzgesagt and brilliant are
collaborating on a six-part video series
about our favorite science and space
topics
kurzgesagt has worked with brilliant for
a bit and we love how they teach you
science and maths in a practical way
by guiding you through problems step by
step so you can actually understand the
concepts behind them
and maybe one day use your knowledge on
problems like space junk
or at least your science projects to
start with
if you'd like even more edutainment go
to brilliant.org
nutshell and sign up for free the first
688 people to use the link
get their annual premium membership at a
20 discount
and also support our collaboration with
[Music]
brilliant